already
all
different
already all
right all right all
right shape's not important shape's not
important shape's not important so here
already
in sh totally your posture totally
Irrelevant
in
[Music]
not net
wasn't see
sh
not
feeling
[Music]
for
other data point that you saw is and all
demonstrated we'll just go for a while
okay I'm doing the same
[Music]
thing
this
one you're like well his
grip his grips get in
you what
grip did some of you see the yielding do
you
see and then I'm seeing
this do you see that you're like in this
position over
lot okay but this one's not that we get
out of the way
yielding right it's again I don't pull
on his skin suit that's what I call it
you like pull
his his skin eventually it pulls the
shoulder eventually it pulls the the
center that's not it okay so in the same
thing where I'm in his center now when a
hand moves this way you guys are taking
it
off in that same Center and that same
Center is in that
movement it's not sometimes you're like
on and then you feel holy cow I feel
like I'm doing muscle tension and then
you go
off no if you if you're going to reverse
it is this same relationship that's
moving this
way same relationship it's now moving
this
way what I would say is do the
opposite of what you want to
do so you want
to he's pushing you want to
yield and then when you throw you want
to
shot okay what I would say is he's
pushing
relax
relax I know it's crazy but just relax
okay if you need
to do a Yin yield as opposed to this
retreating yield okay so don't take it
off instead come around
slightly around
slightly meaning here's his power Vector
come around
slightly don't make it
big just around
slightly and as you feel his pressure
and you feel your mind want to flex
don't
flex release more and more and keep
going around more and
more and we're going to use a little
mixture of internal
external so
here I'll go around slightly oh crap
keep going around and as you keep going
around keep releasing tension keep
releasing tension everywhere you feel
the T everywhere you feel the
tension release and go
around tension I'll release and go
around
okay so pay
attention you can do that in very odd
[Music]
ways
as you learn okay I kind of see what's
happening then you don't need any you
don't need any of it and so to risk it
risk it what are you
risking oh he's got me okay let him get
you then go you're told to release okay
um and you're like what the hell does
that mean what does it really mean okay
because you we go like this he pushes
and we go release do say say release
okay but it didn't look like that when
he released okay first thing
all
language is
poetic if you if you sit here and you
go uh you know the
uh the fifth fcia of the elemental
off it is entirely
poetic language does not language points
to it as much as it points away from it
okay so
when you have somebody that is saying
release you cannot make the mistake of
just go what does release mean to
me you have to treat it
like a scholar would that's studying
another
culture you have to hang out you got to
learn the language you got to figure out
the context and you have to do as much
probably more work figuring out what
it's not than what it is do you get that
okay so we already know it's not that so
you guys that's off the
table okay it's like you're you're
you're you're trying to learn
Japanese and you see two little animals
and somebody goes you but one was a dog
and one was a cat and you thought it was
cat and they go next time you see a cat
and you go you and people go
what and then you need to go okay enu
does not mean cat it was the dog you get
it you can't keep going to the next cat
and
going no no no cats are dogs okay so no
no none of that is
what I mean by release
okay if it was I wouldn't be
mentioning the kind of emot
psychological
dichotomous functioning of my mind do
you see that if it was all purely
physiological okay so same thing as he's
as he's
pushing this is scary to us do you see
and that is one reason tying it to the
first question is we're doing it like
this
we're out here like this you see
or one arm starts to
dominate and the other one is just in a
state of flexion like why is my arm here
just relax your arm do you
see
so if you look at it that way the only
constant is not whether my arms go in or
out the constant the only one between
everything is my mind how do I
spiritually experience him that is the
only
constant so when we talk about release
however you're understanding it you have
to understand that that
is probably what is most important how
you are psychologically experiencing it
okay so if you take that understanding
and you're trying to do this next thing
he's pushing on me on all that pushing
on me instead of going he's pushing on
me you want to say my mind is making him
push on Me My Mind Is Made there's a
there's a old zen story where they were
asked
who who was going to be the next Abbot
and the master said
uh is the is the is the wind moving the
flag or is the flag moving the
wind and the various disciples are going
oh the wind's moving the flag and the
flag's moving the wind right and then
one dude goes my mind is moving the flag
okay it's very similar here my mind is
making him push on me
there's
nothing true about it in terms of he is
all objectively pushing on
me so that's why what I try to do here
is give you a little
poison take some push off you see but
you see what he's doing oh
oh you take some push off and then he's
pushing on me
again so keep taking the push
off don't go here
now keep going around
[Music]
him and what we're trying to do is I I
did have my mind he was pushing on me I
took some push push off but now you
smell weakness and your pushing mind
comes back and you push on
him instead treat it as a releasing
drill a releasing of what drill a a
releasing of the desire to push him okay
so he's pushing me I'll take some energy
off do you see oh crap keep going around
him keep going around him not not here
not up his arm can you yes yes you
can I'll keep going
around and as I feel the urge to push I
keep releasing my mind just keep
releasing my
mind
hold on I'm not
throwing that's a
throw here's the bite release the
bite
observe how relaxed my hands
are he's he's pushing he is
pushing Watch the watch the bottom head
it's just
hanging it too is not
going it's doing the same
Circle you guys say he's got he's get
why is he getting physically
tired why cuz he's pushing the doing
bench press the whole freaking time
okay
so that's about as good as we can get at
a certain point you have to accept the
first principle the mind is moving the
flag okay and then the second thing you
have to do is you have to go it's kind
of like the
Matrix I'm going to change my mind okay
try it again okay so you're trying to do
all that and conceptually structurally
that's kind of what's Happening uh but
there's also the quality of what's
happening okay you cannot
confuse uh that there is not a quality
to your skill whether it is the skill of
Awakening or skill of C DOA okay there
is a quality to it uh it is a perishable
skill okay so
uh
there's a couple things you can notice
here okay
[Music]
um let's see uh we'll have you be n on
and Andrew you
be we're back to laying on
here
okay switch
rolls okay
uh we'll get and Drew out and so you had
one one ability in in the last
UK uh and it
presented
opportunity okay but if the UK has the
skill we're looking
for where as she if she's touches you're
already in her body well the same
thing's going to be
here
so this is the marker you want to
notice the more connected I am with my
center for the person who's
not they will never it will fail every
single time
okay
but for the
person who is connected with their
Center on AA who is connected on their
Center it actually takes less less
movement okay takes less
movement right so he's going to really
project
me and that's his effort every time can
you see last movement every time do it
every time
you kind of course do it with bigger
movement and you'll get a bigger
reaction because of what he's doing
okay um now this
again there's another marker so let's
say
not as much Center connection not B it's
not it's not bad okay it's just not at
that other level
okay so as she goes to touch there's
always a little
lag in her Center as she disengages it
upon cont just a little a little lag do
you see that okay now I can use that to
keep developing myself
but if I am trying to throw you and
you're trying to not get killed I will
always come out of your grip do you
understand that so I I she's going to
push and you see I have to pull the
strike as I'm going do you get it do do
you understand you look confused you get
it okay so I I'll slow down what I'm
talking about so uh as as she
pulls herself out of the technique she
opens that Yin space that was making her
not projectable opens her up to the same
Center that projected someone boom and
just knocks the F out of you do you
understand and then you don't get you
only get one rep as you get okay do do
you get it
so
I will I can never hit him in the face
because his Center will always be
projected out so la last time I did
small movements to his projection you
see he's trying to project
me and I did small movements to get
projection but if I do big movements I
still I will never get near his face do
you see that I try to hit his face and
can't hit his face but it launches his
body you see that
so this is what I'm talking about we you
cannot make it a kind of conceptual
drill like we've been doing you see a
practice
release okay it's still a martial art
and his ability as my ability as UK uh
to displace him is what makes me
projectable it's also what keeps him
able to go full speed and never punch me
in the face do you get it in this case
that would be the target but standing it
would be the groin or it would be the
knee or it would be something else
okay
so I
feel you're moving more in the right
direction if as UK you make yourself
more
projectable then you let your fear get
you and you try to take the energy out
you're only milking the drill that took
strikes out
okay try it again